Bad news for Donald Trump's former personal
attorney, Rudy Giuliani. He may be facing
felony charges. The website Law and Crime is now
reporting that Fulton County, Georgia District
Attorney Fanny Willis is reportedly looking into
whether her office can prosecute Rudy Giuliani
over a series of false statements and
conspiracy theories that he was peddling
during a session of the Georgia state legislature
late last year. Remember that tour that Rudy did
during which he ultimately got coronavirus,
where he was doing all sorts of events at state
legislatures, filing court complaints and all
sorts of different things? According to The Daily
Beast, with an anonymous source familiar with
the matter, Willis is researching whether Georgia
Code 16, 10, 20 could be applied to the things
that Rudy said before a Georgia Senate panel
in December of twenty twenty. Rudy told a
Republican group of legislators, quote, You
were the final arbiter of who the electors should
be and whether the process is fair. The other way
to look at it is it's your responsibility
if a false and fraudulent court is count
is submitted to the United States government and
it's clear the count you have right now is false.
And what Rudy was claiming was that there were
two hundred and thirty one thousand odd ballots
together with no return record at all, that one
hundred and thirty four thousand votes were thrown
out. But you kept six thousand votes where there
was no return record for them. Rudy implying that
there were phantom votes. And of course, all
of these claims were very quickly debunked
even by Republican elected officials in Georgia.
But the question is whether Rudy Giuliani here
may have committed a felony by intentionally
misleading senators, as well as the people of
Georgia and the United States, perpetuating the
disinformation. And under the law in question,
it is a crime to knowingly and willfully falsify,
conceal or cover up a material fact or to make a
false, fictitious or fraudulent statement and
representation before any department or agency
of state government. Now, in general, these laws
are used to prosecute people who are interviewed
during investigations and they say things that
are untrue, knowingly untrue. And it makes it
similar to you're not allowed to lie to federal
agents. And there are other Trump associates at
the federal level who have been wrapped up because
of that. It's not typically used in. This exact
way, but what Rudy Giuliani did in the aftermath
of the 2020 election, as well as Sydney Powell and
Jenna Ellis and others, is also not typical.
So there's no question that this would be.
It would be significant if the D.A. chose to go
after Rudy Giuliani on this, it would be a big
expansion of investigation by district attorneys
within a state. But certainly Rudy Giuliani here
could be in significant legal issue. And listen,
even if it doesn't go very far, the possibility of
it going places is likely to lead to to require
Rudy Giuliani to be well represented by counsel
and magga making attorneys get attorneys,
everybody around Trump needing to hire their
own attorneys. Even Trump's own lawyers. Now, if
it ever comes to it, I am completely convinced
that Rudy is going to sort of adopt the position
of Sydney Powell and Tucker Carlson, which is no
reasonable person would believe. What Rudy said to
be true doesn't necessarily mean Rudy was lying.
But it certainly suggests that, as Fox News
lawyers have argued, when Tucker says things
that don't correspond to the facts, it's because
it's hyperbole. It's a performance. It's an
entertainment program. He shouldn't be expected
to be saying things that are factual. When Sydney
Powell said Dominion voting systems this and, you
know, electors that and all of this other stuff
that nobody should have believed that what she was
saying was factual, really, because she sounded
pretty serious when she was saying it. I assume
that that's the defense that Rudy would take. And
what's amazing is I've already heard a reaction
to that from Trumpet's who are saying, listen,
Sidney Powell still believes that it was
stolen and Sidney Powell was serious when
she said the election was stolen. This is just
an election defense saying no one really could
have believed that as a legal defense is just
a legal defense. So she doesn't get in trouble.
We all know the trumpet's and Kuhnen people are
saying, we all know that the election was stolen
and she was telling the truth, but now she's
only saying this to get out of legal trouble.
Now, what's interesting is obviously the election
wasn't stolen, but it's certainly Sidney Powell
seems bonkers enough that she really may believe
the election was stolen and she really may be
using this legal defense to get out of legal
trouble. That's possible. But that doesn't make
it true. As we now know, there is no evidence
whatsoever that the 2020 election was stolen.